so great getting to talk to you both
what a cool idea for a podcast you both
are rewatching every episode of beverly
hills 90210 which is almost 300 episodes
tori how did this whole idea come about
we well were not just we weren't just
best friends on camera
we're best friends and like we're almost
like life partners you're my female life
partner
my soul wife um
so you know we love working together and
doing
things together and you know you want to
it's great when you can have the best
both worlds
in life and in work and we have that
partnership and we wanted to do
something together we kind of wanted to
do like a girlfriend show and just talk
about
we've been friends for 30 years and that
journey of how like
it's very rare to keep the same friends
that you were friends with in high
school because we all
grow and different things happen in life
and jen's been the one friend that you
know
our friendship has gotten even stronger
through all the decades and things in
life
um and then we decided like the fans
really you know they want to know what
happened on the show
so we decided to do a re-watch and watch
it all together and give you some
behind the things and also share a
friendship
right but the thing about getting tori
and i in a room together is
we talk a lot so when she says we she
means me
we didn't end up going off on tangents
so who knows what's going to come out of
our mouths
oh yeah but see that makes for such a
great podcast people love
that um now i read
or i i heard jenny that you've actually
never watched a full
episode of beverly hills 90210 so what's
this whole process going to be like for
you
it's going to be eye opening um
yeah i i've never sat down and really
watched
an episode and you know absorb the whole
thing
i'm excited because i missed so much and
i know it was a great show
but we were so busy and so wrapped up in
making it that i never really got to
appreciate it so i'm really excited i'm
really excited to start from episode one
we're with tori and with the fans and i
think it's gonna be a lot of fun
that's gonna be so nostalgic and i feel
like right now especially at this time
in our life for so many people
people are really wanting that yeah i
think it's
true it's like comfort food kind of
oh i love that we're comfort food
we're like mac and cheese
i love mac and cheese can you hear them
i know and you're the gluten-free mac
um are there any specific episodes
that you're excited to look back on tori
anything specific or any episodes that
you're dreading to watch back
oh my gosh uh
she loves the pilot i mean we we did
re-watch the pilot when we were
uh creating bh90210 so she loves that
one
i love as my character progressed
because i felt like i was super awkward
and
it was hard to deliver the word high
in different ways because i had a very
small part when the show started and it
evolved
um you did it beautifully thank you
thank you
um i want to see like all our beach
apartment
scenes i want to see those um when we
were roommates
uh when we owned a store together we
always loved peach pit scenes and peach
pit after dark those were our favorite
scenes to shoot because it meant
the whole gang was together and we would
usually shoot those late on a friday
night
and um and laugh
and drink and drink in the dressing
rooms
remember that you're older
welcome let's save that for the podcast
oh sorry
you'll see me here you'll see i'm just
gonna say so this is what we're gonna
get on the podcast you guys are gonna
give us a lot of behind the scenes what
really was going on
i love it good we want that
um you guys all seem so close not just
youtube but the rest
of your 90210 cast do you guys have like
a group chat how do you guys keep in
touch with everyone
we do have a group chat yeah who created
that i think
wasn't it gab that made the group chat
um
or was it yeah but then but remember we
were all like
sharing really private like mermaid used
to call me this
and like things like that and then we
realized there were like two random
people on it
by mistake we didn't know what those
were
how did that number even get on the
chain
it was someone we knew but it was like
she was trying to connect
up for something else and that happened
yeah and he was probably like
what are they talking about and we were
like oh my god what were we talking
about
yeah you've been friends for 30 years um
you've worked on other projects together
so how do you guys find that balance
between your friendship
and your working relationship or is it
the same thing
it really does carry over onto all the
roles that we do
because yeah you can't can't hide it um
are kind of just closeness and bond and
we're so familiar with each other that
we can say and do anything
in front of each other and i think that
a lot of times that's
not easy to get with a co-star so that's
why we love working together
and we are we just are adamant about
continuing to create things that we can
do together
and we both have that desire to do
things that kind of push the envelope
and go beyond you know the norm
and i think we love creating projects
like that yeah
we just work really well together like
we don't fight
we like and we both have our strengths
in our work relationship and i guess in
our personal relationship
and we just know each other so well it's
i mean it's really
an interesting dynamic to see us in a a
room
like a work room like at a pitch or uh
writing a script or something because we
have this
language that no one else can spot or
understand
that's literally we'll be sitting next
to each other and i go
and she knows what i'm talking about or
just a look and we're both like
got it i love it
um you know this show first premiered 30
years ago what does it mean
for you guys to have not only you had
such a strong fan base
back then but still such a massive fan
base now i mean people feel so connected
to your characters and the storylines
what's it like having that support
so many years later the
og fans are one thing those fans are
are bread and butter those are our best
fans they know everything they are
so devoted to the show and to the
characters and to the actors
and we're so appreciative of all of that
but now
seeing like a whole new decade of people
starting to watch the show and
appreciate it and know who kelly taylor
and donna martin are and
you know it's just weird to continue to
live on
and continue to make new fans of the
show
and we love we see such strong female
bonding because we will get
generations like daughters and moms
they're like
she's like the mom will be like i grew
up with you but now my daughter and i
are
bonding over re-watching the show
together and
it's starting conversations and just a
whole new generation gets it
and um you know we're all about we were
entertainment we were
um conversations when it was a different
time a happy time and
and people celebrated and came together
to watch
entertainment as a family as friends and
um it's nice to know that our show still
keeps that going
now obviously fans cannot wait to hear
both of you guys dishing on all the
behind the scenes
you know antics that were going on with
the show but will you be inviting
other nano toronto cast members on the
on the podcast
yes we will it's an open invitation
obviously but we
we um we hope that they'll come and play
with us
because it's always fun when we get
together definitely and and
we had the great experience of having
last summer
and being able to all be back together
working
um obviously we're in each other's lives
but we're really excited
like we had so many guest stars over the
years um to have
people that you know we have we really
haven't seen 30 years like
come on and do fun little spots with us
so we're excited about that we have so
many people we can reach out to
that's awesome now in a preview clip for
the podcast you discuss jessica alba's
claims that she was told not to look at
the cast
in the eye and you both seem pretty
shocked about that so what do you make
about that whole thing
i mean i have no recollection of it i i
can't imagine that ever happening
i never said that to anyone else in my
career and i've worked with a lot of
people so
um but yeah tori you don't remember that
either right
we really really prided ourselves
on being welcoming because all of us
had done other shows where you come in
and they're all a tight knit group
and it's hard being the new person and
stepping up
and performing and especially we knew
like it was a big
show and how intimidating that could be
so i remember jen and i
always said hi to every actor especially
an actress
like you know yeah um just to have that
girl code so it was shocking we actually
and i have seen jessica over the years
and she is such a lovely human
so we would really like to when we
re-watch that episode have her on
and go through her experience and kind
of get to the bottom of
of how that was even said to her by
somebody
you